the secret service has concluded its
investigation into a bag of booger sugar
found in the Biden White House and
concluded that they cannot identify any
suspect according to the Secret Service
despite combing through security systems
and indexing several hundred individuals
who entered the West Wing The West Wing
which is perhaps the single most
surveilled and secure place on planet
Earth
the investigators were unable to find
any fingerprints that of course was the
investigator's first mistake if you want
to identify the owner of some Cartagena
nose candy you don't check for
fingerprints you check for nostril
Prints but regardless Hunter's nose is
currently scrounging like a pig for
truffles to find the next foreign
Shakedown to score another 10 percent
for the big guy so he just like his
entire family and his family's staff
they're all unavailable to face any
consequences I'm Michael Knowles this
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers
delicious good ranchers great meat at a
secure price 30 bucks off your order
with code Knowles kwles go to
goodranchers.com use code Knowles kwles
today
the Biden campaign and Biden White House
have a big political liability right now
that political liability is Biden's
refusal to acknowledge one of his
grandchildren that's finally bubbling
over we'll get to that in a second first
though
the bidens are just totally protected
they're totally protected
I've been to the West Wing on just one
occasion but went into the West Wing I
can tell you firsthand
people know where you are at all times
there are cameras everywhere there are
people watching everywhere you are
searched like crazy it's smaller than a
lot of people think it is it's not some
big wide open space it's it was built
for smaller people in a smaller time
if they wanted to figure out whose Coke
this was they would have done so but the
secret service is going to look the
other way because the big guy
doesn't want
let's say it's not a member of his
family even though very likely it is
doesn't want people within his inner
circle prosecuted for bringing Coke into
the White House so they're just going to
move along Move Along nothing to see
here there was a little glimmer of hope
over the past couple days Republicans
grilling Christopher Ray director of the
FBI on Capitol Hill trying to see if
amid all of these Biden scandals the
document Scandal the bribery Scandal the
potential payoffs 10 for the big guy
is Biden getting investigated at all and
the FBI starts to maybe give us a little
hope and then pulls it right back
did Joe Biden take payments from barisma
or any other foreign companies as vice
president president or private citizen
Biden as you may know there is an
ongoing investigation being led by the
U.S attorney in Delaware Mr Weiss
appointed by President Trump in the last
Administration that our Baltimore Field
office is working with and I would refer
you to to him as to what if anything can
be said so the president is under
um he is under um investigation I'm not
going to confirm or speak to who is or
isn't under investigation for what I'm
simply going to he's not under
investigation I didn't say that either
by long-standing Department policy and
practice I'm not going to be confirming
or denying a quiz or isn't under
investigation
so he hangs out a little bit more at the
top than one might expect he's saying
there is an investigation in Delaware
going on he's saying this in response to
question about an investigation for Joe
Biden and then he immediately walks it
back but let's say that there is let's
say the U.S attorney in Delaware is
investigating Joe Biden for taking
bribes from barisma from China from
wherever
does anybody seriously think they're
going to hit him with this does anybody
seriously think that there was an
investigation into the Coke in the white
house which would be extraordinarily
easy to identify and frankly all of us
have a good gut instinct of whose it was
to begin with
they couldn't do that they said oh no
yeah the investigation was inconclusive
does anybody seriously believe that the
investigation is going to be anything
but inconclusive in the case of Joe
Biden's bribery no of course not they're
going to drag this thing out they're
going to slow walk it and then nothing's
going to happen as a result now speaking
of slow walking investigations
there was a bit of strange news coming
out of the doj in the last two days
which is that Ray Epps
is going to be charged Ray Epps is this
strange figure from January 6th Ray EP
sorry
January 6th the worst day in the history
of America the worst cool day time so
rayaps is this odd figure from January 6
because he is the most prominent guy
that we have on camera we have on audio
multiple times
urging people to break into the capital
on January 6th he was so officious in
his calls for the mob to get unruly and
to aggress on Capitol Hill that a group
of people around him when he was calling
for this said he was a Fed said wait a
second you're just trying to egg us on
you're a Fed fed fed and we're chanting
it all around him but he kept it up and
he kept chanting for people to go into
the into the capitol he was on the FBI's
website he's still he still appears in
an FBI tweet Most Wanted people from
January 6th
but he wasn't charged with a crime he
wasn't arrested he's like the only guy
from January 6 that that was not
arrested or charged for the crime so a
lot of people have suggested that he's a
fed the the suggestion that he was a Fed
was then bolstered by the liberal media
defending this guy don't forget the
liberal media had called genre six the
worst day ever and it was the almost the
end of the Republic and it was a coup
d'etat
and yet they're defending the most
prominent instigator of January 6th that
didn't make a lot of sense glowing
Profiles In The New York Times a
constant defense of him now rayap saying
he's going to sue Fox News for
defamation
probably in the hopes that fox will just
settle out of court and now the doj
comes out and says Ray Epps is going to
be charged so the timing of this is
convenient
at the same time that that rayapse is
bringing a lawsuit against Fox News to
try to have a Shakedown and get some
money and maybe further tarnish Tucker
Carlson's reputation in the liberal
media
the doj is saying okay well we're we are
finally going to arrest him
but that doesn't answer anything
why did it take two and a half years why
did the doj round up every Midwestern
granny who had the audacity to take a
photograph in the capital rotunda on
January 6th they rounded them all up
within about a week they threw a lot of
them into prison they throw a lot of
them into solitary confinement
yet this guy the most prominent
instigator of the whole thing whose
location we've all known because he's
had these glowing magazine and newspaper
profiles
the doj Waits two and a half years what
is this about I think they're hoping
that this puts to rest the conspiracy
theory that Ray Epps has some
relationship with the federal government
to me this just adds fuel to the fire
that this seems even more bizarre than
had they not charged him in the first
place doesn't explain a damn thing seems
a little bit like smoke in mirrors now
there is some good news coming out of
the doj and it actually relates directly
to me we'll get to that in just one
second first though when you want to
talk to all of your friends about the
threats and the joys and the the news
that's going on in this country
you got to check out pure talk right now
go to puretalk.com you know a company is
looking out for you when they actually
upgrade your service and don't even
charge you for it great news for new and
current Pure Talk customers pure talk
just added data to every plan and
includes a mobile hotspot which is
absolutely magnificent four no price
increase whatsoever if you've considered
pure talk before but haven't made the
switch take a look again for just 20
bucks a month you will get unlimited
talk text and now 50 percent more 5G
data plus their new mobile hotspot this
is one of the many reasons that I love
pure talk it's a veteran owned they only
hire the best customer service team
located right here in the great us of a
that alone makes it worth the switch
most families are saving almost a
thousand dollars a year while enjoying
the most Dependable 5G Network in
America not a similar Network the most
Dependable one remember you vote with
how you spend your money so stop
supporting woke companies that don't
support you when you go to puretalk.com
Knowles you will save an additional
fifty five zero percent off your first
month because they actually value you
puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk Wireless
for Americans by Americans
so you remember when the libs tried to
blow me up in Pittsburgh this is a story
happened a couple of months ago I had a
campus speaking event
a lot of radical students tried to shut
it down the administration at Pittsburgh
tried to shut it down legislators tried
to shut it down they couldn't do that
because it's a public school so there's
something called the First Amendment the
event went off but then the anarchists
showed up and they set the street on
fire and they burned me an effigy and as
I was walking onto the stage they threw
an explosive at the building cops made
us walk back in but we did the event
anyway and we wouldn't let them
intimidate us okay well the great update
here was that the FBI arrested the the
two anarchists who got this explosive
and threw it at the building and they
indicted them as well there's a further
update which is that the torch antifa
network has taken responsibility for
this attack that
that missed I'm still here
so antifa which the libs tell us does
not exist has issued this statement this
is specifically the torch antifa Network
thanks to Andy Noe who has just done the
best reporting on antifa out there
they've said breaking update
the torch antifa Network a collective of
violent cells that include Rose City
antifa has claimed bombing suspects
Brian Pepe de Pippa and Crystal depipa
as their members these aren't spring
chickens by the way this is a 36 year
old man and a 40 year old woman a
married couple that decided that what
they were going to do on a Tuesday night
or whenever the event was was to show up
in Pittsburgh and try to blow up a
speaking event where two people were
debating a matter of public policy and
and anthropology for that matter uh
antifa goes on they're soliciting
donations
or I'm sorry this is from Andy no there
are soliciting donations for the
extremists using PayPal though it
appears PayPal has paused The Campaign
which is good they're now soliciting tax
deductible donations using a far left
non-profit Daryl Lamont Jenkins was
revealed through court documents to be
one of the leaders of torch antifa
according to Federal investigators
dipipa traveled across the country in
recent months repeatedly set off
explosive sensors at airports for RDX
but of course the TSA let him get on the
airplanes anyway
so
the libs are going to tell you antifa is
not real well if antifa is not real that
would be news to torch antifa which like
Isis is claiming responsibility for this
terror attack if antifa's not real then
who are the two people who just got
arrested wonderfully by the FBI and
charged by the doj there are many other
anarchists and antifa members who
identify themselves as antifa members
who have been totally LED off the hook
for violence in recent years but at
least these two have been prosecuted and
presumably one of the main reasons they
were prosecuted is they're explosive
that they threw at the building went
into a crowd of about a dozen cops and
injured cops on the scene which which
escalates the issue even more all of
which is to say antifa is a real thing
it's a real organization they should be
rounded up and thrown in prison they
they should be investigated like the
mafia is investigated like the Ku Klux
Klan is investigated I'm sick of hearing
about the Ku Klux Klan from the libs the
the libs pretend that the Ku Klux Klan
exists I don't I don't think there are
five members of the Ku Klux Klan in
America if there are I think every
single one of them is an undercover
agent spying on the other ones they
don't they don't even know that the
other ones are feds they're very very
few of these people and yet the way the
media treats them they're the greatest
Terror threat I mean this is the way the
doj even talks about the great Terror
threat in America's white supremacy show
me the clan Hood I don't see it anywhere
then they point to these other groups
they'll say look at the Patriot front
I love it they call it a front it's a
little on the nose for the Hollywood
scriptwriters the Patriot front is a far
right white supremacist organization
marching and having all sorts of
displays covering up their faces
what are these guys actually doing
the the so-called Patriot front front is
going up and has really flamboyant
displays
at the Lincoln Memorial or something and
then they go home they go back to their
homes and Langley wherever they live
that when when they do show up with
actual right Wingers the right Wingers
usually push them away like the proud
boys or any of these other right-wing
groups where's the threat meanwhile
antifa for years now has been attacking
maiming killing people across the
country showing up to every prominent
right-wing event and then during the BLM
Riots of of 2020 decides to torch the
country for eight months see the shining
sea
and the FEDS don't do anything about it
until now until now this is really good
stuff I don't want to be too harsh on
the FBI especially the FBI for arresting
them in the doj for charging but we've
got to go further folks this is an
organization we have history in this
country of going after not just
individuals but organizations you can do
it for the mob if you can do it for the
clan you certainly can and should do it
for antifa now speaking of
political violence Emmanuel macron the
leader of France has just received an
unpleasant package in the mail
he received a severed finger
from a living human being
this was sent to the official residence
of President Emmanuel macron according
to a report from the London evening
standard showed up at the Elysee Paris
Palace in Paris no note was included in
the package
uh the investigators then took the
finger and put it in the fridge
like the regular fridge where they keep
their coffee and sandwiches and things
because they they wanted to preserve it
so that they could investigate it
further uh so far no analysis has come
out would seem a little bit threatening
or if it's not threatening at least a
lot of people are concluding this is the
evidence that whichever person mailed
this to macron is just totally crazy to
which I say how dare you
how
closed-minded and bigoted of you to
suggest that this is evidence of someone
who's gone a little bit crazy who needs
psychiatric help you know what I call
this I call this fist affirming care
that's what happened here and it's so
wonderful that this fist affirming care
is being put on display at the highest
levels of national politics in France
frankly in the name of progress
the name of liberalism I think we need
to exalt that sort of thing here
that that was a man who identified as
fingerless
he yes he had a finger assigned at Birth
but he identified as fingerless
and I'm just so so happy that he could
get the care that he needs I'm sure he's
he's doing wonderfully now and thank
goodness
that when we're talking about other
anatomical parts
America is much more Progressive than
these regressives who would suggest
there's something disordered about that
can you imagine
I think I'm I don't think I violated any
rules from Big Tech
in my commentary on the finger
speaking of dubious Medical Treatments
this is a bad one
this is a bad one the FDA has approved
the first ever over-the-counter birth
control pill
the pill is called Opel it will be
available without a prescription it's a
daily oral contraceptive sold
over-the-counter
this is bad
this should not be permitted I won't
even say we should ban it we should just
keep the current system in place which
is that you can't get birth control over
the counter there are a lot of reasons
as to why the Liberals are thrilled
about this they want
sterility they want sterility and
promiscuous sex and everyone to be
miserable and as we follow the Liberals
sexual ethic everyone has become more
and more miserable over the last 60
years okay obviously that's what they
want the Libertarians
are probably fine with the
over-the-counter birth control thing
there are many conservatives ten years
ago who would have said oh I'm all for
that let's reduce regulations let's let
people choose to do whatever they want
the conservatives of course are going to
say no this is a bad idea and there are
a number of reasons
the really hardcore
philosophically consistent conservatives
will will name the really deep reasons
as to why this should not be permitted
first question would be what good does
it do what good can possibly come out of
over-the-counter birth control pills
well then people don't need to go get a
prescription in order to have mostly
demeaning promiscuous sex well then
people can have fewer children we have a
dying population the the birth rate in
America is below replacement and has
been for a very long time is that a good
thing to have fewer children I don't
think so is it good for individuals to
have fewer children I don't think so
it's good for society no it's not what
other good comes wrong well uh people
will have more bodily autonomy yeah it's
true I guess you have the bodily
autonomy to hack your arm off too is
that good though is that does that lead
to human flourishing no I don't think so
okay
but then
even if you're not a really hardcore
conservative even if you're a little bit
moderate you're in the middle
what else is going to come from this
well miners are going to access this
stuff
your kids your daughter is going to
access this stuff or she will have the
ability to if you say listen honey
listen 13 year old daughter I don't
think it would be good for you to have
promiscuous sex I think that would be
bad physically for you you might
contract some sexual
sexually transmitted disease you might
become pregnant not know what to do
about that
you
you might be used and abused but it
could also cause a lot of psychological
problems if starting at the age of 12 or
13 you're just used for the sexual
ratification of man without any
consequence whatsoever because they'll
have you take these pills furthermore
maybe there are some questions I know
you're not allowed to raise this
possibility but but a lot of women have
especially in recent weeks and months
maybe it's not good to pump yourself
full of a bunch of chemicals starting at
a very young age without talking to a
doctor without talking to your family
without without really
paying a lot of consideration to this
maybe that's not a good idea to do that
sort of thing
that would be the more Centrist kind of
view of it what good comes from this do
we do we have a surplus of babies in
this country do we have do we have too
much sexual restraint in this country no
I don't think so
and so the only way to oppose this is
for the conservatives to stand up and
the only way for the conservatives to
stand up is to get rid of all this
stupid nonsense about maximizing
individual autonomy that is not freedom
freedom is not just doing whatever you
want
whenever you want to do it
legalizing all the drugs legalizing all
the weird sex stuff legalizing
mutilating your body that's not Freedom
that is slavery to your bassist
appetites conservatives used to know
that we kind of went a little crazy for
a few decades there I think we're coming
back out of it now though
we need less weird sex stuff and we need
more
babies and restraint that would be very
good you know what else we need more of
good meat where are you going to get it
good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use promo code Knowles
if you have not heard yet the FDA
approved lab-grown chicken for sale
yeah
meat formed in a lab will soon be coming
to a store near you if you prefer meat
grown in a pasture instead of a petri
dish then you need good ranchers not
only do they sell real meat from real
animals but they sell the best meat this
country has to offer from Steakhouse
quality cuts of beef to better than
organic chicken everything good Rancher
sources is from local farms in America
right now you get 30 bucks off with my
code Knolls at goodranchers.com
these guys have the best meat in the
business the burgers are the best
burgers I have ever had at home in my
entire life we had them just the other
night and then last night I went to a
steakhouse I was at a dinner formal
dinner at a steakhouse sweet little
Elisa cooked good ranchers steak at home
I was envious of her because I was at
the steakhouse eating the steakhouse
meat I know her steak was better go it
is just the greatest go to good ranchers
right now is goodranchors.com use promo
code nulls kwles you will use my code
Knolls get 30 bucks off any box
goodranchers.com goodrangers.com
American Meat delivered despite the
lackluster economy the daily wire is
thriving and not only that we are hiring
we are currently looking for a senior
copywriter to join our fast growing
marketing department
as a senior copywriter you will
collaborate with copywriters creative
directors and designers under the
guidance of the executive creative
director to craft compelling and
conversion focused marketing copy for a
variety of media in fact you'll even
have the opportunity to write the ad
copy that I am reading to you right now
so it better be good and you better know
your punctuation and your Grammar this
position will primarily focus on d2c
copywriting what is that I have no idea
it's working across the entire daily
wire brand umbrella the position is
based in Nashville Tennessee if you are
interested in joining our team go to
dailywire.com careers right now
speaking of cultural developments
The Screen Actors Guild please prepare
yourself sit down
pull over if you're driving this is
gonna this is going to be tough
The Screen Actors Guild is going on
strike
okay moving on the SAG someone sag is
the Screen Actors Guild it merged about
10 years ago with after the American
Federation of Television radio artists
uh voted unanimously to go on strike and
they will be joining another strike in
Hollywood which is the writer's Guild of
America strike and that means
effectively that unionized Hollywood is
shut down and sag is kind of a crappy
Union back in my wayward youth I would
occasionally work with the Screen Actors
Guild as a professional actor and it's
not a great Union because they're at any
given time like 99 of its membership is
unemployed because actors have hard
times getting jobs generally and so all
of these radical leftists who are
largely unemployed just voted to go on
strike but the the
sag union doesn't do a lot for actors
generally The Writer's Guild actually is
a pretty good union for its members sag
doesn't do all that much and so in
recent years a lot of professional
actors a lot of huge name actors have
have gone Phi core which a financial
core which is to say they don't they
don't really go along with the Union
they'll pay their dues because they have
to as a result of a court case but they
don't really care the influence of the
Screen Actors Guild has waned
dramatically just as the influence of
unions especially in Hollywood has went
Hollywood has waned dramatically and
that's really the point here
the writers are going on strike the
actors are going on strike does anybody
care
when was the last time you went out to
see a movie
I bet just judging by box office numbers
the last time you went out to see a
movie was to go see the sound of Freedom
starring Jim Caviezel which is a movie
that was made largely outside of
Hollywood
Jim caviezel's a terrific actor he's a
big Hollywood star
the movie was funded basically by just a
bunch of kooky conservatives and then it
was made by a bunch of Highly skilled
professionals who were disenchanted with
the way that the Hollywood studio system
works
other than that what shows are you
watching I'm not watching any shows
right now you know what show I'm
watching right now occasionally I'll put
on an episode of Father Brown from the
BBC
I don't I don't even know what's coming
out of Hollywood the only movies that I
would be even tempted to see in
Hollywood
it's Mission Impossible I guess just
Mission Impossible
I don't even know I'd like to go see the
last movie star on Earth Tom Cruise
maybe I would go see him in a movie
other than that I don't even know what
they're producing I'm a culture vulture
I worked in Hollywood for a considerable
amount of time I've worked in New York I
like the Arts I read poetry I read plays
I should be
the
number one audience the number one fan
for these things and yet I'm tuning out
and you're tuning out and this is
reflected in the completely collapsing
viewership of the Academy Awards the
collapsing viewership not just in movies
and theaters but even of the big
Hollywood films on streaming it's over
guys so okay you're gonna you're going
to protest okay you don't have any
leverage anymore
fine the writers and the actors are
going on strike fine by me man that's
fun we're gonna go watch sound of sound
of Freedom speaking of power Brokers
turning to the 2024 race there's a
report out
with bad news for the DeSantis Campaign
which has struggled since its launch
suggesting that top donors are
considering a flip to Tim Scott
uh Tim Scott you know nice fairly
moderate Centrist Republican senator
from South Carolina
I don't know that I buy this report if
the report is real
come on man that's not going to work
it means that the donors who don't want
Trump are souring on DeSantis chances so
they're looking for an alternative
I I really like Tim Scott personally
it's not going to happen
just looking at the numbers looking at
the political realities it's not going
to happen could Tim Scott
in some World become the number two guy
to Donald Trump if DeSantis campaign
really totally collapses and all of the
anti-trump forces rally around Tim Scott
Maybe
I think though at this point
donors who are trying to take a
candidate from three percent to the
nomination
they're just setting their money on fire
DeSantis himself who's got almost 20
percent
the odds that he would be able to take
the nomination right now are quite low
and I know that people are very upset
with me for this guys I'm
I'm like the last conservative pundit in
America who's not actively working for a
presidential campaign and I'm just
calling it like I sees it and people are
pulling their hair out they're saying
but no but in 2016 but in 2012 but in
2008 I'm saying guys that doesn't matter
we haven't had an analog for this kind
of a primary since 1892 because that was
the last time that you had a one term or
running for a rematch
so yes Donald Trump is not the incumbent
but practically speaking in many ways he
is like the incumbent that's why these
other other guys are not going to catch
fire and the other problem here I love
Tim Scott he's a really nice guy
but Tim Scott is a very has a very
conciliatory tone he's really nice as
I've just said and if you think that
this moment in 2024 is the moment for
like a really nice conciliatory guy to
meet in the middle and work across the
aisle and all Shucks were all on the
same team
you don't know what time it is you got
to go get your watch fixed that that's
not where we are right now the two
candidates who have a real shot at the
nomination right now
or Trump and DeSantis and the left field
candidate who's done a lot better than a
lot of people predicted is Vivek Rama
Swami what do all three of them have in
common
they've all bucked GOP Orthodoxy and the
nice nice work across the aisle just cut
taxes ignore the culture they are all
extreme culture Warriors in their own
ways
and and they're the only guys with any
momentum whatsoever or any any real shot
at the moment donors you've got to know
you gotta know what time it is money
cannot buy you
the nomination money alone cannot buy
you the nomination just ask president
Jeb Bush now before we go you know what
I'm just gonna have to leave this this
is I tease this is what I do now I tease
in the show
Joe Biden has a big political liability
that I've called out for a while because
I think it's actually my least favorite
thing about the guy but he's mostly
gotten away with it until now and it's
the fact that he doesn't acknowledge his
seventh grandchild
the love child from Hunter Biden and
even the White House is beginning to
have to acknowledge this and the
campaign team is being told to try to
avoid this question as best they can but
we don't have time because we got to get
to the mailbag right now so sorry that's
a little bit of a tease uh when you want
to look good where are you going to go
when you want to look a lot better than
any of these politicians where you're
going to go you're going to go to
genucel right now go to genucel.com
Knowles our friends over at genu cell
sold out of their Dark Spot Corrector
and our listeners have been begging for
a restock begging legged dog on your
hands and knees well I've got great news
just in time for the summer it's back in
stock geniuselle's famous Dark Spot
Corrector has it not one but three
Cutting Edge ingredients and goes to
work fast to Target sunspots dark spots
liver spots even old discoloration both
on your face and your hands you can now
enjoy your summer sun Beach and
barbecues without embarrassing spots
geniusell's most popular package also
features their summer Essentials such as
the best-selling Ultra retinol
moisturizer with a powerful retinol
alternative for safe use in the sun you
will be amazed at how quickly you see
the results or 100 of your money back
guaranteed I love the owner of this
company Coptic Christian from Egypt who
left there came over here for the
American dream go to geniusell.com
Knowles right now get your dark spot
corrector in the and you sell most
popular package genucel.com Knowles
seventy seven zero percent off Junior
cell's most popular package all orders
will include a mystery luxury gift while
supplies last genucel.com
slash nulls my favorite comment
yesterday is from Hugh Jordan
who says for future reference Knowles
has made it clear he's not endorsing any
of the GOP candidates for the primary
yet thank you very much thank you the
one guy who gets it everyone's trying to
shoot the messenger over here the people
who are
completely only gun Hall on Trump
they're attacking me for being too harsh
on President Trump the people who were
totally bought in on DeSantis they're
attacking me for being too harsh on
DeSantis I'm being harsh because it's a
primary and I'm not working for any of
these candidates and I'm just calling
them like I see some folks and these are
tough guys and they got thick skin and
if they can't handle a little criticism
from yours truly how the hell are they
going to take on Joe Biden huh now it's
time for my favorite moment of the week
when I get to talk to you in the mailbag
the mailbag is sponsored by Pure Talk
go to puretalk.com Knowles to get 55
zero percent off your first month take
it away
hey Michael I have a friend who recently
lost his mother I've been praying for my
friend and his family as well as the
mother's soul I have also been praying
for her body as it has been made known
to me that the family will be cremating
our body and having a reception I don't
believe the family will be burying the
ashes afterward but this is what the
mother wanted
um my question is how should I go about
attending this event because I want to
be there for my friend
but I don't know if I should be worried
about any sins as cremation makes a
mockery of the Resurrection thanks
I share your view of cremation I have
had loved ones family members who have
been cremated
not my Preferred Choice I do think as as
a symbol it it does make a mockery of
the resurrection of the body and I think
that's why as our culture moves away
from its traditional religion of
Christianity cremation is becoming more
and more popular that said I don't think
it's a sin to be cremated
even the Catholic church now allows for
cremation post Vatican II unfortunate uh
so I don't think it's a sin to to be
cremated and I don't think it's sinful
for you to go you know
Port your friend at his mother's funeral
or whatever kind of post Funeral Service
they have if she were cremated
I don't I don't see any uh sin or some
stumbling block there at all
just as I don't think it would be sinful
to go attend a weaker Liturgy of of
almost any sort if the point is to go
pay your respects to the dead pray for
the Repose of her soul and help your
body I I think you're okay I think you
might be
you might be missing the forest for the
trees there if you're if you're a little
too worried about that I share your
reservations but no it's okay go support
your buddy and pray for your your
friend's mother okay next question
hi Michael this is the shukmeister
you'll be happy to know that for the
time being I've kept Mr McGillicuddy
from forcing my future Trad wife to work
at the widget Factory unfortunately
though the only reason that so is
because she doesn't exist in my life
right now in all seriousness I wanted to
tie this into a topic you brought up
recently about how IVF commoditizes
people specifically that a baby from IVF
is a good end from a bad means can we
not extend that rationale to dating apps
I'm a young Catholic gentleman in my
mid-20s and I have a hesitation about
using them because I feel like they
commoditize people the end is good in
that people are getting in relationships
but the means to get there is swiping
left or right on a person who has hopes
dreams talents and identity all behind
that screen just Loosely crammed into a
few sentences and pictures on the apps
you and everyone else are the product is
that feeling Justified or am I just a
bit too old-fashioned love to hear your
response thanks
the feeling is Justified and you might
be a bit too old-fashioned both of those
things are true
yes there's something a little
distasteful about putting an
advertisement for yourself up where your
prospective spouse is just judging you
based on not only your looks but on
pixels on a screen and a couple written
words but that said what happens when
you go to a bar
when you when you go to a bar and you
dress nicely and a woman puts on makeup
and the man throws on a jacket and he's
trying to look cool or whatever and he's
ordering the drink you you are also
putting yourself on display
to be physically attractive to the
opposite sex to then perhaps go on a
date and then perhaps dig a little bit
deeper so to to some degree it's the
same thing happening in the dating apps
albeit in perhaps a more concentrated
and therefore distasteful form in the
dating apps would it be better for you
to meet your future spouse in a more
Lively and organic way perhaps you know
high school sweetheart or a friend of a
friend or you get set up on a blind date
or something like that yeah sure and
maybe that would be better but the way
people date now is on the apps I think
the the issue of the dating apps is
in part
a trend of capitalism not of Communism
not of just far leftism but of
capitalism too to turn people themselves
into Commodities to be consumed yeah
that's a problem but another problem of
it is the abstraction of the identity
from the body and which is a trend that
you see all throughout our culture and
you see it especially in dating apps
that when you are first encountering
somebody through a dating app you're not
really encountering them you're
encountering a disembodied
simulacrum of that person not the real
person in flesh and blood but just
pixels on a screen and that's a problem
as we move more and more into virtual
reality we're we're losing real reality
as we live more and more in some
metaverse constructed by Mark Zuckerberg
we're spending less and less time in the
fullness of the beautiful world that God
has created for us to live in so that's
something to worry about this is why
when people go on a date on dating apps
and they say wait a second you look
skinnier on your pictures or something
like that uh this is just a baser
expression of the same problem which is
you're not really looking at the person
you're just looking at some zeros and
ones on a screen that come together to
form
a hint or a representation of that
person so yeah
it's fair to have all these reservations
but also maybe just go out and date the
girl and and
move past that uh ugliness in our
culture whether whether it's
the way people dress or comport
themselves or where they meet or how
they meet even sometimes through the
medium of a dating app and then get to
the real stuff
quick as you can okay next question
hey Michael Knowles my question to you
today is about the VAC Rama Swami so
I've watched every clip interview speech
of his that I can find and honestly I'm
blown away everything that I've seen has
pointed me to believe that he is the
right candidate and that he deserves my
vote now with that being said and
running the risk of sounding
close-minded the only drawback I see is
that he is Hindu so I believe we're one
nation under God and I believe that to
be the Christian God so how do we
reconcile this can I vote for someone
who doesn't believe in the god or in the
religion that America's founding
principles are based upon if a candidate
came up and said that they were atheist
I would not vote for them solely based
on that so as a Conservative Christian
can I vote for someone in good conscious
that is a different religion than mine
and doesn't believe in Christian morals
I appreciate it I look forward to
hearing back from you it's a real
concern
you're going to hear a lot of squishes
say that's not a concern at all don't
worry about that thing a man's private
religion doesn't mean no it didn't of
course it matters religion is a very
powerful thing and it forms the way we
think about just about everything so
it's a real concern I would
I would ask Vivek how he thinks about
religion because one of the Curious
aspects of Hinduism is you could get 10
Hindus into a room ask him to explain
religion to you you could get 10
different answers 10 very different
answers so I would ask Vivek to to talk
about religion to you that's a legit
question and then furthermore let's say
he says look I'm uh I am a Hindu you
know I'm not I'm not even a Hindu that
leans toward monotheism though many of
my Hindu friends do and maybe Vivek does
too I'm I don't know there's some other
kind of Hindu or whatever then then you
get to your question which is can I vote
for someone to have public trust who
doesn't share my religion now I would
point to someone like Benjamin Israeli
Benjamin Israeli a Jew one of the
greatest Prime Ministers and one of the
most important conservative figures in
the UK in recent memory you know men by
recent memory I mean the last 300 years
or so
um so
can that happen yeah I certainly think
it can Hinduism is is a step even
further than Judaism but
you know we live in a
in a world where things are not going to
be perfect so you say well I want the
perfect Christian leader who's got this
particular view of Christianity and
who's going to do this thing in public
life and he's going to be this smart and
he's going to be this talented he's
going to have this this and the other
thing and you're you're not going to get
all of that so
if you put say Vivek up against some
nominal Christian whose understanding of
the faith is so warped that as a matter
of public life and the discharging of
his public duties he would end up being
worse than an atheist say then I think
you just have to make a Prudential
practical judgment there and I would say
if you're if you're attracted to the
vague as a candidate and you've got this
one hold up where you haven't seen any
practical consequence of that yet then
I would say you'd be crazy to just throw
the guy out immediately I would press it
a little further you know keep a a
proper caution about those views and try
to prod them a little bit but uh as a as
a practical matter
now you judge the tree
by the fruit okay next question
hello there Mr Knowles this is the
conservative monk I'm so happy to
finally get to talk to you
I'm coming at you with not a question
but a comment
I want to implore you to please recant
your dismissal of the existence of our
Interstellar overlords
they are among us they have been here a
very long time
I have it on good authority to tell you
that if you recant your former
statements and beg forgiveness at the
feet of our Interstellar ambassador to
our Intergalactic Masters Ambassador
Walsh
then you might forgo working the salt
mines of kaglar 9 for the remainder of
your life
please do so as many of us are very fond
of you
it's also noteworthy that I do not know
Ambassador Walsh nor did he put me up to
this what hold on what I did I did I
said the things what
I gotta go
thank you for that missive I appreciate
that
with my friend Mr Walsh on vacation for
the past week or two
I had not been barted by such inanity in
a while so uh
I'll take your suggestion under
consideration and let's get to a written
mailbag before we get to the member
block it is fake headline Friday too by
the way so I'll need your help to make
it through the fake headlines
but before then greetings Mr Nostradamus
writes Sac a few episodes ago you spoke
about the possibility of a cigar talk in
your show what's your go-to brand
I myself am a fan of Monte Cristo their
epic is my favorite but my usual is
their Platinum my first cigar was the
Kahlua from Drew Estates
that has been discontinued what was your
first cigar thanks love the show
especially the members block or as I
call it the sanctum of Nostradamus
could go on and on I don't have nearly
enough time to go into this
I think cigars are very important I was
at a wonderful cigar dinner last night I
really enjoy them I have very particular
tastes in cigars
developed over many years of enjoying
cigars my first cigar was a machine made
Cuban cigar called a Guantanamera which
is a really low quality cigar it's short
chopped up filler but it has that good
Cuban tobacco flavor and I was 15 what
did I know and I really liked it I
always hated cigarettes I don't like the
devil's lettuce but I really liked
cigars and shortly after that I
discovered Oliva Cigars which at the
time were not nearly as well known as
they are now and I just adore Oliva
Cigars
um their series out Perfecto I still
love I think dollar for dollar you you
really can't beat them
um I love uh then got into Tattoo cigars
and Don Pepin and my father I got into
that padron I love I mean you know the
list goes on and on of the brands but
I've been thinking about this a lot
lately because I do have particular
tastes and cigars that I've cultivated
and I was I was
occasionally you can get custom Blended
cigars and those kinds of things so
anyway
I'll be exploring all of these options
as a lot of people write into me they
say Michael what what should I smoke I
want to get into this does one smoke by
oneself yes maybe with a book wonderful
relaxation opportunity just one smoke
socially yes one absolutely does you
know another great aspect of cigars for
the fellas
is it's if you want to have a guy's
night and maybe you love women but you
don't want always women hanging around
all the time cigars are a great way
because 99 of the time they can be woman
repellent and sometimes women even like
it when the men smoke cigars one because
it you know is very manly and virile and
thematic and increases your testosterone
and all these things uh but two they
recognize that men need their own spaces
sometimes and they need a little
relaxation working very hard so anyway
all of that to say
I'm giving more thoughts on how to
incorporate cigars more into the
Michael Knowles show universe
now in that universe
it is fake headline Friday and I need
your help to find the fake headline
among the real ones the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
become a member and use code Knowles a
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]